we just looked at coleman bar graphs we
said all right we know how to do seven
link but sometimes
don't worry about the individual data
points okay just tell me how many are
all in here how many were on here etc
okay now moving from these guys
over to line graphs there are two main
reasons why
and you always have to ask this question
of why because sometimes you'll have to
choose like they won't tell you
which which representation you want to
have they'll expect you to know what are
the advantages and disadvantages of each
seat you can choose okay so i've got two
reasons for you and these are important
these are worth getting down
because they'll guide all of your
drawings later on okay
why line graphs firstly if the data
you've got
have a look down here right if the data
you've got connects
right and what you're interested in is
like some kind of trend
like what happens from day to day okay
if you are searching for a trend
that's actually connected between the
different things you're measuring
then you actually want to see well what
happens when things change do i go up do
i go
down i'm not interested in which one's
like bigger or smaller
i want to know what's the trajectory of
this thing okay so what happens is you
just get the tops and you join them
with the line okay so if you're
searching for a trend that's the first
reason why you have a line graph
secondly this is a loon to yeah why are
these separate and why
sometimes we want them together if
you've got data that has nothing to do
with like
the bb is in the races may be completely
disconnected
but monday and tuesday are clearly not
disconnected one flows into the other
okay so if you have data that's
continuous or connected
then it makes sense to draw
or connect the dots
because there really is a relationship
between the adjacent
data points on the graph okay so really
really quickly because you've done this
before i'll just draw this one up for
you
and you can finish in period two i've
got this data here which is all about a
share price that's fluctuating up and
down throughout the week
okay i've already started in this bottom
part over here
i'm missing a vertical axis what would
you like me to put there
okay so this is the share price of how
much should i go up by
each size ready to go for five now i can
go up by five and i think that's a good
choice because
you can see these are quite close
together all these prices okay
now here's the thing though on my graph
i'm only gonna go up by
tens because
um i'm just going to like it's not just
important to have these be able to
distinguish them i also need to make
sure that i'm not just overcrowded with
like
imagine i say this to a company before
if i had like
a step of one every time so i'd have 60
steps here
i might as well not have any steps at
all because i won't be on the top of the
path they'll just be sitting on top of
one another
so i also want them far apart enough
that i can see them and i can still tell
the difference between 45 and 48 on this
ground okay
so for instance let's have a look 45 is
going to be halfway there
48 is going to be a bit higher 55
52 and 40.
six okay so you're going to get your
trend
like that okay so being able to track
how it goes along through time
the really important thing about
searching for a trade is therefore you
can
number one you can work out what happens
between things
and number two you can actually project
forward you can work out a trajectory
question four
when do you
are you talking about like what happens
over here yeah sure um it kind of
depends on the data that you've got
so you can see like my data it starts
from here and i have no idea what's
going on over here so therefore
it wouldn't make sense it wouldn't
communicate in three for instance
to do that and i also can't really do
this
or that because i have no idea what's
going on so i'm just gonna start my data
um you'll see in period two we'll talk
about what happens when it's like well
monday to friday if i had saturday and
sunday as well then this is kind of like
a
circle this is a loop right so we'll
show what happens when you can draw it
like that
but basically it's totally fine would
you just
start there that's where my data starts
so that's where my graph will start as
well